uh trump's economic advisor larry kudlow
was visibly confused and sounded off
uh when it came to simple arithmetic on
cnn yesterday i think you'll find this
disturbing because
it is wild confusion about basic numbers
combined with a very odd delivery from
larry kudlow which we'll talk about in a
moment now the setup is that there's
been a debate about
what is the next stimulus package going
to include
when is the next stimulus package going
to happen what's the
unemployment piece and how does it all
fit together
larry kudlow puts together a word salad
where it's not even clear he knows the
numbers he certainly can't
express them but it's not even clear he
knows what the numbers are cnn's dana
bash tries to figure out what the hell
is larry kudlow talking about
she can't do it kudlow is confused and
it all falls apart
uh i don't want to be specific because
you might hold me to it as you should
but i think it's going to be in a couple
of weeks and i think it's going to come
to about twelve
hundred dollars per person uh that's a
huge you keep saying twelve hundred
dollars per person
are you talking about in addition to the
unemployment that they're already
getting
i don't know the payroll that
i'm i beg your pardon the twelve hundred
dollars will come from the payroll tax
deficit
we're going to get to that okay all
right because this is there's a lot of
numbers here and it's it's it's a little
confusing i want to get a payroll
in a minute go ahead it should be 800
bucks i beg your pardon it should be 800
bucks
for the unemployment 800 or 400
no it should be four it should be eight
hundred dollars
if the states step up we're prepared to
match
that should be come out four hundred
dollars federal
four hundred dollar states
okay we'll move on because i think this
is
that's not what the president said and
it's a bit confusing um
and i think the fact that it's not
entirely known is very telling
twelve hundred per person payroll tax
deferral
wait no stimulus actually it should be
800 for unemployment
no it we're prepared to match 400
federal and 400 state
but we're matching wait but what does
that even mean you're matching 400
federal
there's really nothing federal to match
it's all state when it comes to
unemployment
and then the federal match or
enhancement is of state unemployment
insurance
if you think i sound confused yes it's
because it's this insane
what larry kudlow is saying he's saying
there's a state match and a federal
match
what does that even mean and dana bash
just white flags
she surrenders and she says let's move
on this is totally confusing it's not
what donald trump is
saying now the second layer is
that not only is larry kudlow presenting
this in a completely impossible to
understand
way it also seems to be completely
different from
what the trump uh what donald trump
himself has said
and when we talk about this matching the
feds contribute
300 if the states add another hundred
but i'm trying to sort out something as
if it's at all clear
and kudlow just was slightly uh
confused he seems to have no idea what's
going on whatsoever and it gets even
worse during this interview here's a
similar confusion about the payroll tax
deferral
not a cut a deferral and larry kudlow
equally confused but the president said
explicitly that if he gets re-election
re-elected he will make the payroll tax
cut permanent
as you well know these funds these funds
go into and help pay for social security
and medicare the president promised
many times not to get social security
and medicare
so isn't that exactly what he would be
doing here
no he will protect social security and
medicare how does he do that and cut
payroll taxes at the same time
well hang on uh when he referred to
permanent
i think what he was saying is that
the deferral of the payroll tax to the
end of the year
will be made permanent it will be
forgiven the tax is not going away we're
still going to have said he would
he said he would still protect if he
gets reelected it was a new campaign
pledge but
i i i no i i i think that he was
referring doing away with it i believe
he was referring
to doing away with the payback of the
deferral
and i think his intent here and it's
written in the
eos very clear that we will take uh
any steps possible to forgive
this deferral that's what he was
actually saying we will protect i just
want to say that's what you're saying
medicare
that is not that is not what the
president said at all
um he said that he said this is the
executive order
okay so that's not what he said people
aren't reading the executive order
they're
they're listening to this well i think
i think he meant the deferral would be
forgiven i think he was saying that
that the savings on the deferral will be
permanent he did not mean
that he's eliminating the social
security tax it's a deferral
that will be forgiven without doing away
with the tax
but trump said he would do away with it
if he's re-elected
but that's not what trump meant
according to kudlow
if you were confused and you were
confused
further by my explanation good it's
outrageously confusing and deceptive and
this is either
it's either or both you take your pick
they're either
all deliberately saying different things
in order to sort of let
everybody take their pick and if they
hear one version that sounds okay
they like it and they say i approve or
they actually don't know what the hell
is going on and everybody's saying
something different or some combination
right that that's always a possibility
we need
to hear from kudlow what trump meant
apparently i mean kudlow is saying what
the president
meant is this absolutely outrageous and
bizarre now i do have to mention one
thing to go back to
larry kudlow's demeanor here people have
been emailing me saying
is kudlow drunk again during this
interview i understand why you were
asking larry kudlow does have a history
of
problems when it comes to alcohol
consumption that's not
anything to laugh at i don't know the
answer in this case
but certainly it's not a crazy thing
to wonder about with larry kudlow his
thinking clearly seemed impaired he was
visibly confused by the arithmetic and
by what he's saying
and by what he's being asked and by what
donald trump said and by what donald
trump meant
it's a you know a verbal ink blot as i
like to say
as far as the alcohol piece is concerned
i don't know i it's it's up to others to
evaluate and judge his thinking was
impaired
by what is definitely a different
question that i guess we will have to
leave
uh presumably for a different day one of
our sponsors
is privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com slash pacman
i've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity
theft and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman